with doc you know he gay
we watched a few clips together talked
had lunch but you know it's not over yet
you know we still all three of us got it
getting a room not just as three it's
gonna be a team effort of making this
work the 15 gone a bench should have to
has to be in that room as well to know
what he needs to do his role and you
know we still got things to build on
what you're still going through the
transition as you know Paul said he's
house hunting everybody still trying to
get settled so then you know that I'll
work itself out and as far as the player
of power you mean I mean I was a free
agent so I really I could choose
anywhere I wanted to go for the most
part I really don't have too much to say
on there
hey guys Miriam Swanson Southern
California news group welcome back to
SoCal you guys and congrats Kauai on the
baby boy question for you guys is sort
of you're talking about the front office
transparency and how that was important
maybe a little bit more to that and then
why was it important for you Kauai to
kind of keep business dealings quiet
during this process just because this
you know a lot of things are made up now
in today's world at MBA you could you
know start a website or blog and you
know push that out and say croisé doing
this quad is doing that but it's always
important to me to you know have a
mutual understanding between everyone
and just be transparent if it's good or
bad and you know I feel like that bill
is a great relationship you know you
know once we had our meeting I felt like
there were tools for the word
nothing really got out and you know it
was a great decision like I said we had
a head coach here with that one owner
that wants to win badly you know not
good for an office with Lawrence your
lunch frankly tinny then you know I just
felt like was a good decision for me
yeah over here bill plasticky Los
Angeles Times for PG and kawaii over
here you both grew up here you
understand the dynamics of the of the
NBA in this town and the giant shadow
cast over the Clippers by the Lakers all
these years how important is it for both
of you to lead this team out of that
shadow I mean as far as the last few
years as far as a basketball standpoint
the Clippers have been better you know
they've been but it's just this media
you know what I mean they're gonna get
the the attention knowing the Los
Angeles Lakers
they've been winning championships for a
long time that like I was saying is just
a media aspect even if we do win you
know who knows how the coverage will
change over and I don't feel like I'm
focused on that I'm just wanna win and
you know I do things that make myself
and my teammates happy whatever is on
our goal in mine you know that's gonna
be my focus and drive to just make us
happy and if we go to the championship
and win and we're not getting no
coverage that's fine with me
I'm good um I mean I just think Lakers
as Lakers we got our own identity we
chasing something else you know we we're
not looking at the Battle of LA you know
we got bigger things in mind and bigger
goals to accomplish other than you know
the shadow and like none of that really
means anything you know they they got to
come out and perform the same way we got
to come out and perform I think for us
at the end of the day we want to be
holding that trophy and that's all that
matters we'll build our legacy and we'll
build our our clipper nation up along
the way
time for one more question
over here
Andrew gray from the Los Angeles Times
there's a lot of anticipation about
seeing what you two can do together on
the court but Kauai last year you had a
lot of success limiting your workload
and at the right time for the playoffs
how important is that to approach this
year this same and then Paul what is
your realistic timetable for being back
on the court coming off here surgery's I
mean last year I was I came in here you
know not fully healthy so you know we
laid out it's pretty much a schedule for
myself and to see what best possible fit
for me for a long term charity thing and
a issue and for what's gonna make the
team better but uh you know this year
coming up I feel like I'm VI full
strength you know it's just one of those
things you just take down a road and see
how your body's feeling and you know
it's a it's a day-to-day thing if if
anything comes up you know how the NBA
season is it's about of 82 games but the
goal right now is to play the season so
we'll see what happens for me there's no
no set date I mean I've been progressing
really really well I'm at a great point
right now in my rehab you know so it's
you know take our time look forward to
returning whenever that day is and just
being 100% healthy well I'd like to
thank everybody that asked questions I
would like now to have doc Lawrence and
Steve come up we'll do the Jersey
presentation for both Kauai and Paul
[Applause]
[Applause]